y siguen resonando los ecos del paro
nacional del miércoles en colombia el
viernes miles de personas marcharon de
nuevo por todo el país especialmente en
cali en donde el miércoles registraron
graves altercados y saqueos pese a ello
la gran mayoría se manifestó de manera
pacífica si bien se volvieron a
registrar altercados con el ejército de
policía algunas organizaciones de
derechos humanos denuncian que al menos
siete personas fallecieron en cali por
disparos de las fuerzas de seguridad
otras hablan de hasta 14 a lo que habría
que sumar una treintena de desaparecidos
denuncias a las que se sumaron desde
human rightswatch
hemos recibido graves denuncias de
abusos policiales por parte de agentes
de policía en colombia contra
manifestantes de cali la ciudadanía
tiene todo el derecho a manifestarse y
debe hacerlo de forma pacífica policía
debe garantizar respeto a los derechos
humanos el gobierno sólo reconoce una de
las muertes ya ha respondido con mayor
presencia militar llegamos con más
hombres y mujeres del ejército y de la
policía a la ciudad
garantizar la defensa y la seguridad de
los ciudadanos
estamos garantizando patrullajes
combinados y la protección de los
principales puntos de la ciudad
congresistas de izquierda se instalaron
este sábado al gobierno detener la
represión el presidente iván duque por
su parte ordenó al ministerio de
hacienda dar marcha atrás a los puntos
más discutidos de la reforma tributaria
convertida en principal motivo para la
movilización según algunos de los
manifestantes las protestas que siguen
durante este primero de mayo no cesarán
hasta que la reforma no caiga por
completo bueno pues el partido es el
momento hasta que ya la reforma
tributaria caiga porque no nos sirve que
vamos a conciliar que vamos a cambiar
las tiene
y queda por ver cómo prosigue en las
movilizaciones en un país que la reforma
tributaria suma una grave crisis
sanitaria económica y el aumento de la
violencia derivada del incumplimiento de
los tratados de paz y mientras